hello everybody and welcome to another
YouTube hangout I'm super excited to be
here with a legend a living legend and
expert on so many topics from sales to
productivity to time management and
leadership and entrepreneurship and
success he's written over 80 different
books many of them many of them went on
to be best-selling books and he's got a
new course out called power productivity
mr. Brian Tracy how we doing Brian I'm
doing great how are you I am amazing
thank you for making the time I know you
have a busy day shooting a bunch of
videos to your channel and I appreciate
you carving out some time for us today
it's a pleasure so we're talking about
productivity in my audience is mostly
entrepreneurs who may be full-time on
their business or part-time and they
want to go full-time there could be
having a job and want to make that
transition this is one of the most
common questions that we get is around
this topic of productivity how do I
manage my time how do I focus on the
right things and I know you've got this
new course talking about it for the
entrepreneur who's getting started and
trying to build this to full-time
business or for the entrepreneur who's
earning a full-time we're trying to get
to that next step what are some of the
tips that you would give them on how to
be productive
well I often ask my entrepreneurs I say
why do you get up and go to bed in the
morning go to work in the morning what
do you get out of bed and they say they
think about it for a while and I said
well the answer is mmm which means make
more money you don't go to work to make
less money or to make the same money you
would have bet you go to work to make
more money so I said no how do you make
more money well it's called SMS and that
means sell more stuff and so you
MMN buy SMSing now if you are not
selling more stuff in the course of the
day then you might as well go home to
bed and pull the curtain pull the covers
up over your head and go back to sleep
because you have no value to yourself or
anyone else and then I start to point
out I notice it we're going to learn
this from a very successful man look
around your office
alright look at my job now what don't
you see in your office and the answer is
you don't see any customers alright so
why are you in your office
there's no customers there you can't
sell more stuff and if you think you're
going to sell more stuff by sending out
tricky email messages then you probably
need some medication or a checkup from
the neck up the only way that you sell
stuff is you go out there and you talk
to customers and you ask them to buy it
and so if you're not out asking to buy
it now what are the three keys to
selling more stuff they are prospecting
presenting and closing prospecting means
finding new people who can and will buy
and pay in a short period of time and
then telling them presenting that your
product or service and why it is the
very best choice for them now and then
closing them and getting to make a
decision today this minute so therefore
all come together is prospecting
presenting and closing is how you sell
more stuff which is why you got out of
bed in the first place now so they
interview the interesting point because
I've been through all of this myself
they've interviewed entrepreneurs and
they say how important are sales to your
business and the entrepreneur ting of
all o sales blood to the brain oxygen
you know to the heart without that
there's no there's no business I say
okay well next question the researchers
asked is how much of your time in the
course of the day do you spend selling
selling more stuff and they say oh all
day long that's all I do it's all I
think about it get up in the morning
think about it all day
and so then they said well alright you
mind if we follow you around with a
camera and a stopwatch for 30 days and
just see how you actually use your time
no problem no problem at all you know
what they found out the average
entrepreneur spends eleven percent of
their time prospecting presenting and
closing whether the other eighty nine
percent is spent excuse the expression
[ __ ] around they doing fun things
easy things checking their email
checking their email again sending help
emails they're making phone calls
they're checking their spam they're
spending so much time 50% of working
time today's wasted if they're not
checking email they're chatting with
their friends they're chatting with
their buddies in there drinking coffee
and they're having lunch and they're
going around feeling like big shots
because they've got their own business
but the fact of the matter is if you're
not prospecting presenting it
see you might as well go home to bed
because you have no value even worse
you're probably a detriment to other
people because you're stopping them from
working by talking to them or sending
them email or keeping them busy email
according to the Harvard University and
so three studies I've read this week is
killing entrepreneurs because they can't
stop they have this irresistible almost
like an addiction to electronic
interruptions and they can't stop it so
just yesterday Wall Street Journal had
this great article which is what I've
been saying for the last five years is
turn it off don't turn it down turn it
off
check it every two to three hours and
then turn it off Oh what if it's an
important message what what you do is
you say this I check my email three
times a day if you've sent me an email
between those times I will get back to
you as soon as I can if this is an
emergency phone this number and that
phone will never ring and then what you
do is view through three three twenty
minute phases a day first of all you do
for your first check is a 10:30 or 11:00
you do not check your email in the
morning because that immediately Adickes
you and you're on email all day long so
you wait till 10:30 or 11:00 check at
once wait till two o'clock check it
again wait till 4:30 check at the third
time on and off in 20 minutes and shut
it down if you can do that you'll double
it triple your productivity and that's
one of about a hundred ideas that I can
give you but if you'll just do that
that'll do more to help you to be
successful in selling more stuff because
if you're not wasting all this time
doing that you have only one choice is
to sell more stuff talk to customers
talk to people and ask them to buy your
product I love the energy I mean you've
been doing this for so many years helped
so many people I still get fired up
about allowing people to add more
creativity and productivity to their
lives I love that message about not
starting the day with email and certain
at 10:30 or 11:00 o'clock what then do
you recommend that entrepreneurs do
start their day with well I'll give you
a very simple process I was teaching
this to someone in Japan yesterday
actually a very large number of people
in Japan yesterday
and it varies it starts with a piece of
paper in you a piece of paper and a pen
or pencil will make you rich and we
won't go into goal-setting it's a whole
separate process but make a list of
everything that you have to do tomorrow
the best time to make your list is the
night before if you make a list of your
whole day for tomorrow your subconscious
will work on your list overnight and
you'll wake up in the morning with ideas
and insights that are sometimes quite
amazing so you make a list and then you
look at the list and you ask this simple
question if I could only do one thing on
this list before I was called out of
town for a month which one tasks what I
want to be sure to get completed and put
a circle around that your list now when
you get up in the morning whatever time
you start and that's a very interesting
point wealthy people start by to get up
in the morning by 6:00 a.m. poor people
get up at 7:00 or afterwards wealthy
people get up earlier poor people get up
later real simple so if you're getting
up around 7 o'clock you're always going
to be poor for the simple reason by the
time you get started the day's
half-finished and now you check in your
email and you're talking to your friends
and then it's lunchtime and coffee
timing and spam time and everything else
get up at 6 o'clock and you develop a
ritual get up exercise then sit plan
your day get organized and start to hit
it at 8 o'clock and the first thing you
do is you start on your most important
task and then you concentrate single
mind to be on that task you do not turn
on your email you do not turn on your
telephone you don't do anything except
that one task and you just do this one
task until it's completed now you've
already agreed with yourself in the
world that there is nothing more
valuable in the world than you could do
than this one task so do this and if you
develop a habit of getting up in the
morning and started and completing your
most important tasks it will transform
your life it's one of the most
incredible productivity habits ever
discovered and every person who
discovers it they see their income their
productivity their performance and their
satisfaction just explode it's very
simple the question is do you have the
discipline do you have the self-control
the willpower to start and complete your
most important task if you if you don't
have
you can develop it with practice if you
develop with practice it soon becomes
easy and automatic and if you just do
this your productivity will double the
first day so what do you think holds
people back they know what they want to
do but they just can't keep the habit
they do it once and then they fall off
the train and then next you want to do
it again and they fall out the Train how
do you make that consistent well you
just keep you just keep working at it
and working it the best way of all is to
plan it in advance
instead of sitting down never start work
without a list and never start work
without prioritizing your list people
sit down and they say well before I make
a list check a little email check a
little spam send something to my friends
see what's going on YouTube and so on
and so forth and then they look up and
it's 10 o'clock and they haven't got
anything of value so what you do is you
have to say you know well you know what
what whether they say that if you
started right it'll it'll it'll work out
right so start it as with on your most
important tasks and do that until it
becomes a habit here's an interesting
thing about checking email is when you
check email it triggers the release of
dopamine in your brain dopamine is a
drug but by the way there's not all
kinds of books and articles and
scientific studies on this and dopamine
is the same drug in cocaine and what it
does is it's triggered every time you
have a shiny object or something new or
different or interesting or sparkling if
a telephone rings next to you you go
ping your brain releases endorphins and
you can't hardly wait to see what it is
so you're talking to somebody and you
could be talking to somebody about
something very serious and your
telephone goes off ping your whole mind
books blank because the middle of
conversation stops you grab for your
phone you pick it up you look at it you
check it out and everything else and
then you come back if you're working on
a task it takes an average of 17 minutes
to get back to the task and then there's
another distraction so another 17
minutes average adult is checking their
email between and and their phone
between ninety five one hundred and
forty five times a day that's very easy
which means they're like attention
deficit
disorder dogs they're just literally
running around back and forth the whole
day at the end of the day they're
exhausted by the way USA Today and and
Harvard approved that you lose one IQ
point for every hour where you that you
leave your email on at the end of the
day you've lost 10 IQ points you
actually become stupider throughout the
day dumber and here's a ask this of my
audiences I say have you ever finished
today we don't think you've accomplished
anything you've been on email responding
to bings and beeps and rings and so on
all day and at the end of the day you go
home and honey says what do you want for
dinner and you say I don't know I don't
care anything I just want to drink
because you're so exhausted you cannot
even decide sit there and basically like
you've just been you know punched in the
side of the head because your brain your
brain is dead and you lose 10 IQ points
you get stupider throughout the day
you've got to turn that darn thing off
if you want to remain sharp you know
what the habit you said I'm going to do
out the habit and I'm going to give
myself up my reward and my reward will
be to check my email after I finished my
first task so so all of success in life
is task completion let me repeat that I
just had a long conversation with an
entrepreneur I almost fell off his chair
I was coaching him and he said he never
heard that before
and then I spoke to my this group I was
telling you in Japan I told them the
same thing and they were just
flabbergasted is the key to success in
life is task completion if you don't
complete tasks you have no future and so
if if if task completion is the key then
what you do is you complete more and
more important tasks and if you start
every day by completing a at the most
important task your brain actually
releases endorphins now endorphins is
another chemical and it's only released
when you do something that is life
enhancing and what that means is when
you do something that is good for you
that enhances your life that furthers
you it makes you happy it releases
energy it raises your self-esteem is
sort of safe if you if you want to be a
winner how do you be a winner where you
win and winning
need to cross the finish line so if you
start to complete a task you're actually
winning and you get a feeling of being a
winner which gives you a suffusion of
energy and inspiration and it drives you
and motivates you to want to get that
feeling again so how do you get that
feeling again you start and complete
another task so I've developed the habit
and people who are successful drop the
habit of starting and completing tasks
so my wife comes in and says dinners in
five minutes so I look at my list I say
okay there's a five-minute task and what
are you starting complete a five-minute
task and each time you complete a task
you get a burst of endorphin the bigger
the task the more endorphin the more
endorphin the more quickly you become
addicted to starting and completing
important tasks and every single
successful person has a reputation for
starting and complete an important task
you want the job done give it to him or
her you want the product served on time
you want the product
completed you want the product
manufacturer ship delivered give it to
him give it her give it to that company
guess they always deliver that's the
best reputation you can have if you want
to get rich interesting and so it sounds
like the completion of the task is
really important to release the
chemicals to feel like a winner if
you've got that off your plate I wonder
how you break it down for when you work
on a bigger project so you're working on
a book you've done eighty plus you're
your next when I'm writing best-selling
books so a part of your your most
important thing is hey I'm on a book
dial I need to get this done obviously
you'll be able to write an entire book
in the first two hours of a day so how
would you chunk it down so that you get
that feeling you want to leave feeling
like you accomplished something right
that you got something done you check
the box how would you break down a
bigger goal for the more time as I I'm
assuming that everybody who is watching
this wants to become rich
sooner or later and sooner is preferable
alright the way that you become rich is
you deliver results that people will pay
you for right well one of the greatest
result tools in the world is called a
checklist and a checklist is very simply
a list of every step in the process from
step one to step two to step three very
much like a recipe that is organized
that says this is what you do to prepare
a particular dish you do these things
and you do these things and you bring
out these things and you take
these ingredients in this order in this
quantity and so on and you put it all
together so some years ago I did
something which was really quite
ridiculous I wrote a book and I promoted
the heck out of it cost me more to
promote the book that I got from from
royalties or advances and then after
three months they told me that we have
no more interest in promoting your book
I said well why I mean we're doing so
well
interviews blah blah blah they said well
after three months the window closes is
when you write a book there's a
three-month window prior to the book
coming out and three months after it
comes out then it closes we go on to
other books your book is now old is an
old story
it's a yesterday's news and I said well
jeez what can I do with that I said I
know I'll write a book every three
months and I made that decision I just
I'm just now working today to finish my
80 second book it'll be finished by
Friday and all with all of major
publishers everyone is published by
major problems no self-publishing and
I'm talking about Simon & Schuster and
while Ian and I have just published four
books with the biggest publisher in the
world penguin Random House and they came
to me and asked for the book so first is
well how do you write a book I say I
take out my checklist and they say the
first thing I need to know we need to
agree on the subject all right and I
only write on a subject that I put in
hundreds of hours of research and
experience the second thing we need to
know is when is the drop-dead date when
are you when do you plan to publish the
book release the book and when do you
have to have it in your hands which is
usually fully six months before the book
is published okay so I work back from
there and then I haven't got a checklist
now I know what the subject of the book
is when the book has to be in the hands
of the publishers and then I work all
the way back to step one and step one
and by the way anybody who wants this
just go onto my website Brian Tracy calm
and just to say Brian says check this
for writing it's free that's 20 points
cuz people kept asking how you write so
many books I've written now four or five
books a year for almost four 20 years
and I say well I'm out of it now I'm
done this last two months I've gotten
for five books for 2017 from this
publisher and that publisher and one
brother publisher wants to and I said
geez I said you know I
we're going to take a break no we want
the books because these books sell they
just kind of tumble over each other one
sells and the second sells and so here's
here's the formula just simply download
the formula like a recipe follow the
formula it takes tremendous discipline
to write a book like I can appreciate
this because you've written your book
you're one word I said writing a book is
like digging a ditch to the horizon can
you picture that
you know you just get you just work and
work and you lift up your head and all
you can see is the horizon you put your
head down your work and work and where
you look up it's still the horizon out
there how or after hour after hour but
you got to get started well I'm going to
check out the checklist it took me two
years to get this thing out so I'm
envious to get a new book out every
three months maybe maybe that list will
help me too for the next version thank
you for the tips I'm looking at your new
course your power productivity course
that you're selling online you have this
training for I guess anybody wants me
more productive I'm really intrigued by
the first lesson which is priming your
mind for success and I know there's
something to talk a lot about having the
mindset for greatness of mindset for
success can you talk about that how it
relates to entrepreneurs and how it
relates to being productive the mindset
for success but many years ago I met a
fellow an entrepreneur like us very
successful and but I knew that for
several years he had been just kind of
drifting through his his career and
sunny took off I mean it's busy he was
just booming his personality was
completely different he was starting
early working harder staying later he
was up he was positive his income had
gone over $100,000 and in another two
years was over $200,000 he was smoking
and so I asked him this question and I
never forgot the answer I said what was
the turning point in your life and he
said Brian he said I finally decided to
get serious I finally decided to quit
screwing around as I was talking all the
time but I want to be successful and I
want to make a lot of money and
everything else then I went home and
watch television and I started a little
bit later and went for coffee with my
friends
in the day and so I finally decided that
I'm going to get serious about this I
put my head down and at that time on I
started to get up earlier I started to
start earlier work harder stay later
don't waste time
hammer Hammer hammer I'll give you
another example very simple no
successful entrepreneurs work less than
6 days a week no successful
entrepreneurs work less than 60 hours a
week anybody who thinks that they can
have balance and work eight-hour days
and spend you know time in their
personal life and so on that's good get
a job working for wages and worry about
money all your life drive a used car
have holes in your shoes and eat
macaroni and cheese because that's what
people do who work from 5:00 to 8:00 to
5:00 every single person who is wealthy
hits it all the time they get up earlier
they start earlier and they hit it and
they work longer hours but here's the
great payoff is they're happy all the
time is if you're doing something that
you enjoy they could talk about your
values your one-word you're doing
something that you enjoy and you're
getting better and better at it you love
your work my partner here is Eric Berman
and Erica I've been together for 15
years and we're talking about self
discipline and what we find is it takes
more discipline not to work than to work
I mean we really have to promise
ourselves and others and block off the
time make non-refundable deposits on
vacations and things like that because
other than that we just love to work all
the time and so we work 10-hour days if
I work less than 10 hours and I'm 72 now
I work less than 10 hours six days a
week I feel that somebody's going to go
to find me out they're going to do
they're gonna take me take me away for
for defaulting on my responsibilities
and so it's really important and if you
are working on something that you enjoy
and you're making progress it gives you
a steady flow of energy you'll find it
the successful entrepreneurs are happy
all the time they're just smiling all
the time they just love what they do and
they want to do more of it now the other
thing is this which is one of the things
we teach in
maximum productivity is is that you've
got to get better and better at what you
do this has to be like breathing and
breathing out all successful people
again studying the habits of self-made
millionaires they invest at least an
hour a day in reading in their field I
spent three hours a day reading I've
done that for 50 years or more I just
read all the time I read on planes I
read on trains every on automobiles I
read at home in the morning I read in
the evenings I read on vacations as you
look at my house I've read more than six
thousand books and more than a hundred
thousand articles when I just got a call
from a publisher saying we don't we
don't have a book from you for next year
can you write us a book and I said well
what kind of a subject would you like
well what would be a good subject and
make him up with the idea get on with it
something like you know overcoming
resistance procrastination lack of
willpower something like that and I said
okay I could write on that subject I
read on it all the time so I could sit
down I could write a book on that
subjects it would what's your drop-dead
date and I've got a drop-dead date I
think it's March 31st or something like
that and and so okay March 31st I can
work by actitude on out of the book in
your hands on time it'll be released by
the end of the year but but the thing is
I'm constantly taking in new information
so people say well how can you write so
many books if you read my books they run
from anywhere from 120 pages to 350
pages and they're chock-a-block jammed
full of content there's no entertainment
books there's no stories about me me me
some people think that they are the most
fascinating person in the history of the
world and so if they write every thought
and feeling they've ever had in their
whole life and every experience and so
on that this is going to be fascinating
reading for other people no nobody cares
about your story everybody cares about
their story but what they do care about
is getting better so they can earn more
money faster so if you want to have a
successful book write a book it gives
people tools that enable them to get
better results faster and easier and
make more money and people will buy the
book by the thousands and tens of
thousands and in my cases by
the millions that's not a mystery oh I
love you curiosity and before we went
live when kind of the green moon getting
set up the very first thing you asked me
was is that your book and yet the
curiosity about the book and what it's
all about and I loved it at reading that
many that many hours a day is is
impressive and I've got a good book for
you to read if you want to add one to
your lisper for a daily well this
morning I got a an ad from Amazon before
I came down here to talk to you and it
was the 12 best articles by Harvard
Business Review best best most practical
articles on business success condensed
into a single book 1495 and what I do is
I automatically click buy when I see a
good book imagine 12 of the best
articles from Harvard Business Review
for 2016 what if there's one idea in one
of those articles that saves me a year
of hard work or doubles my income so I
don't say oh it's not just $14.97 and
the habit of gravity blah I just okay if
you see a good book or a good article or
good magazine with a good article in the
magazine buy it automatically don't even
don't even hesitate because my friend
Jim Rohn used to say it's not the cost
of the book it's the cost to your life
of not knowing what's in that book is
the cost to your life many people have
become rich as a result of a single book
I was meeting for four hours just early
last late last week and this man I
bought the book Think and Grow Rich by
Napoleon Hill when he was about 20 years
old no high school 20 years old salesman
not a good salesman he read the book and
he read it and he read the book and it
changed his life he started the business
at another business he said he read the
book every single year for the last 50
years and he made a billion dollars
every time he read the book and that
million dollars added to another million
dollars these were seven hundred forty
million dollars today he said and he
reached the book every single year and
every year he makes another million
dollars which is close on to the pile
which was goes onto the pile and onto
the pile and and I've heard that kind of
a story forever one book
and make you rich my book maxima
achievement he said you read maximum
achievement he said it was better than
think and grow rich you wish he'd had it
20 years before because in your book the
one word they give a person one insight
one idea about what they're doing or not
doing that could chase their whole lives
but if you don't read it it's not
possible for you to be exposed to that
idea hello we're getting tons of love in
the live chat best you prose saying he
loves all your book they offer great
tools and ease saying thank you for
sharing brian is my hero I'm already
saying I have a lot of respect for Brian
and Evan so this is this is great
often a ton of value ah one of the
sections in your power productivity
course really struck me it's lesson
eight which is you are responsible and I
think a lot of people will blame the
president for them not being successful
and blame their parents and blame the
economy and blame their lack of
educational resources you know we always
have a reason for not being more
successful and that I love that lessons
I think it really speaks to the heart of
successful entrepreneurs can you talk a
little bit about accepting
responsibility for where you are
currently in life and where you need to
go I am one of the books are thinking of
writing if they keep on asking me to
write books it's going to be called
turning points and I just realized over
the last couple of years that each one
of us has turning points is our lives
are going along and the turning point
could be abrupt the getting fired
getting going bankrupt the end of a
relationship or a marriage or something
like that it could be an abrupt turning
point or it could be just that sort of
like a road that just kind of turns and
you kind of took this road and then when
you look back years later you realize
that that turning point changed your
whole life forever
it could be just picking up a book I
have had a person write to me he picked
up one of my books
at you pay for a dollar for it in a used
bookstore he said within three years he
was a millionaire he said he'd never
didn't go to use bookstores if there it
was and is in a big box and he just sort
of attracted to the title and he picked
it up and it changed his life forever
and so you never know about these
turning points so going back to answer
in your
question I was 28 years old I was I
dropped out of high school I was working
on a construction job I lived in a small
apartment it was 35 degrees below zero
Fahrenheit outside I had to take three
buses I did get up at five in the
morning and take three buses to my
construction job and then I had to take
three buses back and get back about
seven 7:30
and I didn't have any money because it
cost me everything I was earning as a
constructional laborer carrying heavy
stuff to live but I'm sitting there and
my look at a little kitchen and a little
bedroom the bedroom and living room were
the same one I have open up a couch to
sleep and close it up so I could turn
around and I had a bathroom that was
about as big as a telephone booth so
here I am sitting there and it's cold as
blazes and I've got no money I got no
television I've got no radio got no
music I'm sitting there and suddenly
like a light bulb and everything about
this as a light bulb flashing in my face
I realized that this is my life this is
my life and I am responsible nothing is
going no one is going to come to the
rescue
nothing is going to change for me unless
I change isn't nothing nobody cares
I was 2,000 3,000 miles from my parents
and I wasn't going back unemployed no
money I've gotten my old car and I drove
it through an intersection and somebody
was drunk and game just ruined the car
and the car wasn't savable anyway it was
about a fifty dollar car at that time so
now I couldn't even drive my old junker
anyway so this is my life and suddenly
it dawned on me I am responsible I am
responsible I am responsible and that
changed my life forever talk about a
turning point
my turn life turned abruptly that didn't
mean that suddenly I was successful and
so on it took a long time because the
second turning point for me I realized
it took over a long time responsible for
what well I'm responsible for my own
goals so the second major turning point
in my life is when I discovered goals oh
my god I still remember I wrote down my
first list of goals in 30 days later my
life had transformed I couldn't believe
how powerful goals are and then the
third turning point I still remember
these I call it my goal and try
was when I discovered continuous
learning personal development that you
could learn anything you needed to learn
to develop any skill you needed to
achieve any goal you could set for
yourself
those three turning points made my life
and then years and years later funny
Stephen Covey became a friend of mine I
wrote the introduction testimonial for
his book seven Habits of Highly
Effective People and if you look at
Stephen Covey his first chapters take
charge accept responsibility Jack
Canfield is a dear friend of mine who
wrote the success principles first
chapter accept responsibility take
charge of your life you'll find that the
smartest people who have ever examined
success say without taking
responsibility nothing can happen but
when you take responsibility which means
no excuses no blaming no criticizing no
complaining once you take responsibility
your future is unlimited question I
still it makes me happy every time I
think about that moment when I realized
I am responsible
I love local people in the live chat
want to see this turning-point video
sorry book get released so you've got
you've got an audience when it does come
out and some are saying that this video
is their turning point so I always have
an impact on on the audience I'm brining
nowhere I know your time and time and
we've got to wrap things up your your
power productivity course is there a
message you want to share for my
audience we've linked it up below in the
description but a message from you about
what it's all about or what you're
hoping people can learn from it
well you're the entire future of your
life is going to be determined by the
results that you get one of the things
that I teach I say what is your most
valuable financial asset and the answer
is your earning ability your ability to
earn money and your ability to earn
money is your ability to get results
that the people will pay you for and so
if you can increase your ability to get
results you increase your ability to
earn money and one of the things you do
it is accept responsibility set goals
and plans all of which we teach you and
also to continuously get better and
better at the most important things that
you do to get results to earn money all
right so
saying that with regard to this program
I always ask people I said how would you
like to double your income anybody here
like to double their income and I'll ask
this of one hundred or thousand or in
one ought incite 18,000 people it
everybody says yes of course I say well
I can give you seven ways to double your
income in the course of this seminar and
so I'll give them to you as the seminar
goes along the right place and I start
the seminar and I come back and I say
well what do I start off with one way
guaranteed to double your income
tomorrow 100% success rate worldwide
would you like to hear that everybody
says yes yes yes I say it was very
simple I said I want you to imagine that
you have two types of tasks you have
tasks a one side and you've tasks B okay
so tasks a are those tasks that move you
directly towards your most important
goals
all right tasks B are tasks that do not
move you toward your most important
goals and even more they move you away
from your goals all right so if you want
to double your income starting tomorrow
do only tasks a and stop doing tasks B
that's all just start doing only tasks a
from the time you get up in the morning
to the time you go to bed at night and I
heard this wonderful one-liner which
will make you rich before you do
anything ask yourself is this moving me
toward my most important goal or is it
merely a distraction a waste of time is
this moving you toward my most important
goal or is it merely a distraction and
if it's a distraction it's in task B
stop doing it it's almost like slapping
a person's hand don't do things that are
not moving you towards your most
important goal what is your most
important goal is to double your income
how do you double your income you get
more results how do you get more results
you do your most important tasks and you
complete that this is not a mystery and
I've had people come back to me over and
over it's I can't believe oh and it
worked
I doubled my income the following we
after twelve years of work in my field I
just discipline myself not to do tasks
be an only do to a say and anybody who's
listening to this I guarantee you you'll
double your income within the next few
days if you just stop doing useless
things those things that are moving you
toward achieving the most important
goals you
and the most important goal you have is
to double your income uncle Brian thank
you so much for your energy for your
constant dedication and making people
better and pushing them to believe in
themselves more for all your books for
all your content still going strong for
the amazing stories that you've told us
the inspiration the live chats blowing
up people are are feeling the love and
tremendous respect for you for you guys
watching check out power productivity
you've linked it up below yeah Brian it
something else you want to say right I
just want them to be you to be sure to
tell everybody you come to WWE Brian
Tracy comm slash entrepreneur
productivity so it's Brian Tracy dot-com
slash entrepreneur productivity and you
get all the information and you know
something that I've always done it which
is a real key to my success is I always
unconditionally guarantee everything
anything that you get from me from a CD
to a two or three thousand dollar
training program I have you take it use
it try it out and if for any reason at
all you're not happy there's no charge
it's the same thing with this program
this is the most powerful single program
this is based on the most popular
program of time management in history of
the world it's in 42 countries P
companies buy this program by the
thousand and revolutionize their
companies even in the midst of massive
downturns and so I always see the same
thing if you're not delighted there's no
charge and so it's the same thing with
everybody listen to this go to Brian
Tracy com entrepreneur productivity and
get started on this program immediately
and if you're not happy that's not
charge but I I have no worries I love
the guarantee well we've linked that up
in this kitchen below guys to go check
that out Brian thank you again so much
your time thank everybody for watching
continue to believe and we'll see you
guys soon Thank You Evan see you site
see you soon do only a tasks